ihr habt es schon am titel gesehen heute
das hier wird heute ein etwas anderes
video denn in diesem heutigen video muss
ich einerseits mich für etwas
entschuldigen und andererseits muss ich
um eure hilfe bitten da fangen wir ganz
vorne haben die letzten vier videos die
auf einem kanal hochgeladen habe waren
alle videos mit marcel dem hilf mit
einer stelle aus den beiden hilf mir
meinen freund messe nicht folgen die bei
euch sehr gut angekommen sind wir haben
glaube ich mit den vier videos zusammen
über über 1,5 millionen aufrufe gemacht
aber es kann auch wieder den ganzen
welches einiges an hält auf und auf
diesen hält würde ich heute mal eingehen
denn ich wurde recht eingehend dafür
kritisiert wie ich zusammen mit marcel
und auch wie marcel über seine
co-darstellerin geredet haben also die
sogenannte ashley in der folge hier noch
mal eine szene
und genau darüber möchte ich heute mal
reden ich möchte mir die einzelnen
szenen noch mal anschauen für die mich
kritisiert habt ich möchte mir anschauen
was ich gesagt hab ich mir anschauen was
marcel gesagt habe ich möchte dazu
stellung nehmen bevor ich anfange
irgendwas zu erklären leute ist eine
sache ganz wichtig und zwar wenn ihr
ashley aus der hilfe der folge meint
folgen mästet nicht kennt wenn er sie
irgendwo her kennt und in kontakt zu ihr
herstellen könnt dann seid so gut
schreibt mir auf instagram wirklich nur
falls ihr sie kennt und falls ihr den
kontakt herstellen könnt weil ich auch
gerne mal ihrer sicht der dinge hören
möchte stellt den kontakt hier schreibt
mir auf instagram at&s gezockt
dankeschön
ich mache dieses video heute hier weil
ich eure kritik als meine zuschauer
ernst nehmen möchte hier als meine
zuschauer seit somit das wichtigste was
ist für mich auf youtube gibt und
dementsprechend möchte ich gerne ernst
den man möchte gerne mich um das kümmern
was ihr sagt ich bin auf der anderen
seite das muss ich auch vorne weg
schicken niemand der zu den leuten
gehört die sich wegen jedem kleinen
scheiß rechtfertigen wollen so ich
glaube ich bin schon mensch der sich
viele gedanken macht aber es gibt ja
auch diese leute denn so sagen sie
online mein nachbar drei straßen weiter
hat angst vor körnerbrötchen deswegen
kann ich sonntags nicht mehr zum bäcker
gehen wisst ihr was ich meine leute so
diese leute gibts ja auch wie jeder
kleine randgruppe irgendwo auf der welt
alles recht machen wollte das bin ich
davon halte ich nichts
aber ich finde wenn man einen fehler
gemacht hat muss man dafür geradestehen
und muss dafür einstehen und das mache
ich heute deswegen geht an dieser stelle
jetzt hier ganz klar eine entschuldigung
raus an
ich kann nur 11 der so erschließt der
name den sie der hilfen erfolgen kann
ihren wirklichen namen
ich glaube wir
dich nicht ganz fair dargestellt und ich
habe nicht das richtige dazu gesagt und
habe nicht dazwischen gerät wenn andere
nicht das richtige gesagt haben sorry
dafür wie gesagt ich würde gerne die
gelegenheit geben dich auch dazu zu
äußern solltest du interesse an haben
also falls sie kennt dann schreibt mir
da dann können wir das machen falls die
lust drauf aber geben wir es mal auf das
ein was er geschrieben habt ihr die
komplette crew gelacht und einem habe
ich auch nie abgebrochen weil sie hat
nichts gegen dich verziert ist das ein
ganz liebes mädchen gewesen aber sie
hatten noch so extrem noch zwei stunden
und ich habe auch gesagt hat wir
brauchen jetzt nicht meine idee flasche
weil es ging einfach nicht mehr
das ist ja gerade eben gesehen habt ist
in dem ersten video was mit marcel
gemacht habe in dem interview teil 1 die
szene an der sich sehr viele leute
gestört haben dass auch ein roter faden
der sich durch die ganze videos mit
marcel gezogen hat dass marcel
tatsächlich recht oft auf den
körpergeruch von ihr eingang ist und
auch sehr explizit so wie gerade eben
gesagt hat sie hat gestunken so und am
anfang habe ich mir auch so gedacht ja
okay bis hin zu nehmen ist so direkt zu
sagen so jetzt kennt mich vielleicht
jetzt müssen ein bisschen besser leute
über die letzten jahre
ich würde an der stelle nicht zu sagen
so sie hat extrem bestimmt sondern ich
würde sagen so sie hat halt ein bisschen
unangenehm gerochen was den dreh
bisschen schwerer gemacht hat also ich
bin da schon immer so dass ich das
versuche möglichst vorsichtig zu
formulieren wollte arbeit an der an
anderer stelle auch ihnen jetzt hier in
dem interview nicht so absägen sollte
motto warte mal das kann aber nicht
sagen weil ich vermitteln wir auch viel
geflogen und ich will auch gar nicht so
tun als wäre das jetzt hier über
dramatisch jetzt in diesem ersten teil
das ist wie gesagt zähler nummer eins
und da haben sich schon daran gestört
schauen wir mal kurz in die kommentare
boxen live statt anfangs fand ich echt
sympathisch aber dass er darüber spricht
dass ihr nach schweiß gerochen hat geht
gar nicht wenn auch sie wird mit
sicherheit auf der straße erkannt und es
wird sich vielleicht darüber lustig
gemacht zudem ein mädchen das nicht nur
eine rolle sondern auch im echten leben
höher gewichtiges ständig dicke zu
nennen finde ich auch richtig schlimm
was nützt es dann immer wieder zu sagen
wie nazis verletzt ist sie dann weniger
ich hab das gefühl reduziert menschen
sehr stark nach ihrem aussehen und das
macht ihn mega und sympathisch das ist
wohlgemerkt muss man auch dazusagen
volks darauf eingehe
ein kritischer kommentar unter ganz ganz
vielen positiven unter dem ersten video
aber gebe mal kurz darauf ein wie gesagt
das thema unangenehmer körpergeruch ist
eins was man schon sagen kann
man darf das schon so ansprechen wenn es
so passiert ist es ist aber auch immer
eine frage der portwein
man kann sagen person xy jetzt nicht auf
sie bezogen aber auch irgendwie eine
person bezogen wieso das ist somit eine
sehr negative form zu sagen oder man ist
immer auf der positiven seite und sagt
auf der vorsichtigen seite und sagt ja
die richtigen ein bisschen man muss aber
auch schon auch die wahrheit sagen
dürfen in deutschland auch im jahre 2020
soll aber wie gesagt das ist eine frage
des tones und dass er hat sich aber wir
wissen wer holt gut okay dann das andere
thema was auch kritisiert wurde was sie
auch in krisen kommentar sehen ist das
thema körpergewicht also die ganze folge
baut der so ein bisschen darauf dass
seine drei partner in diese erschwert so
ein bisschen kräftiger ist also so sagt
er bisschen mehr auf den auf den knochen
als der durchschnittsmensch das kann man
auch in der form schon so sagen denk ich
mal und dann habe die fall wie man damit
umgeht ob man das jetzt die ganze zeit
herausstellen und da drauf rumreiten ja
ich schon ich tue mich damit schon
schwer so weit ich finde dass man das
nicht machen sollte also es ist kein
kein guter zug leute wegen ihrem
aussehen fertig zu machen also man kann
es durchaus bemerken in einer
vorsichtigen art und weise also man kann
nicht so tun als hätte ein mensch der
ein bein hat auf einmal zwei beine und
weil sie also man muss schon bei der
realität bleiben leute aber respektvoll
und das ist hier nicht immer der fall
gewesen die wir weiter mocki 09 09 was
war das größte andré die kosten
tatsächlich ja recht haben beschreiben
wie sie gestand zudem ja ist ja auch
nicht schlimm gewesen
es war für mich schon recht haben so
okay jetzt mit dem zweiten teil im
zweiten interview was mit messi gemacht
habe das war das zweite von vier videos
insgesamt gehen jetzt auch diese szene
ein wiedersehen wir dass da auch dieses
thema einerseits irgendwo aussehen so
typ und so andererseits aber wieder ganz
klar bringt das thema
der körper darauf angesprochen wurde so
david seiten view hat sich schon die
anzahl an leuten gehäuft dies
kommentiert haben auch berechtigterweise
was man am anfang zu aussagen muss ist
die haben die ganze videos am stück
aufgenommen ja also in einem abend weil
marcel nur begrenzte zeit in köln man
hier das heißt wir hatten auch nicht die
möglichkeit auf kritik einzugehen von
euch die natürlich dann erst kam als wir
schon alles abgedeckt da muss man auch
dazu sagen
aber ja gehen wir jetzt hier darauf ein
es ist wieder das das gleiche thema er
sagt jetzt hier das schlimmste für ihn
war die kurze szene so und dann als ich
nach frage warum war es das schlimmste
sagt der gestank und wenn ihr mal drauf
achtet schaut man genau hin
seht ihr dass ich da auch schon sachen
raus geschnitten habe okay die kosten
tatsächlich ja recht haben beschreibt
wie sie ja ich stand zudem wenn ihr
gerade drauf geachtet habt ihr gesehen
dass danach so stark was weggeschnitten
wurde also muss ich auch zu meiner
verteidigung sagen ich habe schon im
schnitt aufgepasst nach möglichkeit
sachen raus zu dem mann kann aber auch
nicht so setzte die jemand sagt so
verhackstückt so hat dem motto auch
jetzt stehe ich hier 13 sekunden raus
und dann da erklingt ist einfach scheiße
untersatz ergibt doch keinen sinn mehr
also in begrenztem maße kann man sachen
rausch 1 habe ich versucht an stellen wo
ich gedacht da passiert das jetzt nicht
ganz fair gegenüber trotzdem haben dann
einige von euch immer noch die meinung
gehabt dass das immer noch zu hart ist
und irgendwo ich ja auch letzten endes
sonst würde ich dieses video nicht
machen unter diesem einen kommentar von
unicorn wird ja ganz interessant ist
weil er relativ ausgewogen ist beide
seiten beleuchtet möchte ich vorlesen
mega meisten solche videos macht also in
marcel ist mir auf jeden fall deutlich
sympathischer als eine rolle aber
trotzdem finde ich seine aussagen
gegenüber es wie auch in diesem video
wieder ziemlich heftig meiner meinung
nach erzählt man sowas seinem besten
freund aber nicht unbedingt öffentlich
vor der kamera war sicherlich auch für
die schauspielerin von ashley keine
schöne rolle und ich denke nicht dass
das sein muss jetzt im nachhinein auch
noch so schlecht über sie persönlich zu
sprechen also ein argument was in diesen
kommentaren ist was auch immer in
anderen kommentaren sondern ist dass man
so etwas für sich hätte behalten sollte
also nach dem motto man hätte das gar
nicht sagen sollen so nach dem motto ja
dass sie nicht sein typ ist oder das ist
irgendwie so ein unangenehmer
körpergeruch ihn gestört hat in dieser
szene und da muss ich ehrlich gesagt
sagen weiß ich nicht hätte man hätte man
das gar nicht sagen dürfe nirgendwo
beschreibt das ja auch die die szene und
die atmosphäre bei den drei leute ich
glaube ist eher eine falle davon wie man
sagt nicht ob man sah
also ich glaube sobald man an dem punkt
ankommt wo man dinge über die realität
verschweigt weil es andere verletzen
könnte begibt man sich auf ein ganz
gefährliches pflaster
weil man dann auf einmal über eine
fantasiewelt spricht die mit der echten
welt nicht mehr viel zu tun hat weiterer
kommentar von mona lisa unter diesem
video dem zweiten video willst du
eigentlich noch öfter erwähnen dass sie
stimmt das muss echt nicht sein das ist
nämlich glaube ich auch mit dem faktor
ist wurde es wurde zu oft gesagt es
wurde zu oft gesagt und auch die
intensität und die wortwahl mit der es
gesagt wurde war nicht ganz richtig als
main kanal und letzten das muss dafür
auch die verantwortung übernehmen
deswegen heißt dieses video auch
entschuldigung oder etwas in die
richtung ja ziemlich video nummer drei
angekommen also die ersten zwei videos
waren interviews mit ihm video nummer
drei ist jetzt eine reaktion in der ich
ihnen auf seine eigene volk vorgehen
hatte 2 kommentare darunter sekretärin
berlin also am meisten tun wenn dieses
mädchen leid es wurde auch so viele
arten und weisen erniedrigt und dahin
unterstrich nach war hat sie nicht
einfach die noch größere arschkarte
gezogen fangen wir an der tochter in
belgien also ein stück weit kann ich dir
schon zustimmen es ist schon so dass
einerseits vor also finde ich einerseits
vor allem in der hilft mir volk also mal
unabhängig davon was ich danach gemacht
habe vor allem mit der hilfe der folge
ist das mädchen eigentlich so die
gelackmeierte weil sie spielt quasi die
rolle von dem opfer was auf den
manipulativen freund reinfeld und sich
von dem westen lässt und gar nicht etwas
abgeht insofern stimmt es dass sie noch
schwere rolle hat ob eher niedrigen das
richtige wort ist weiß ich nicht mein
letztes endes ist immer auch eine
schauspielerin die eine rolle spielt so
und ich meine gerade die rolle ist ja
ziemlich lächerlich aber sie ist auch
schauspieler also also das ja nicht das
gleiche so vor allem würde ich nicht
über mich selbst sagen dass das was wir
in meinen videos gemacht haben
erniedrigung ist erniedrigen zu krass
das wort dafür
der nachbar hat gesagt hat sie nicht
einfach die noch größere arschkarte
gezogen und ja ich habe schon gesagt
mehr oder weniger wissen es schon so
einerseits weil sie hat in der folge das
dummchen spielte was nicht etwas abgeht
und den eigenen körper ruiniert und
andererseits hat sie zumindest in den
videos in dem ich mit marcel gemacht
aber nicht die möglichkeit gehabt sich
selbst zu verteidigen weil sie nicht da
war
ist ja klar wer sie da gewesen ich hätte
also falls ihr das denkt ich hätte
natürlich nichts dagegen gehabt wenn sie
auch da gewesen
umso besser dann hätten wir noch mehr
leute gehabt die dazu was sagen können
so sehr gerne hätte ich mit beiden
mädchen gemacht aber sie war immer nicht
da deswegen würde ich auch gerne das
nochmal mit ihr machen um ihren
standpunkt auch darstellen zu können
auch ihre meinung dazu einfangen zu
können ist ein zentimeter mehr
ich habe dir doch gesagt ein bisschen
disziplin unwillig kriegen wir das so
stolz auf dich heißt jeder will dass
seine freundin abnimmt und ich will
einfach zwei zentimeter mehr noch mehr
mit ein bisschen wille und disziplin
kriegen wir das hin besser als jetzt aus
dem vierten video also aus action nummer
zwei mit marcel und das ist ein satz an
dem sich auch wiederum viele von euch
gestört haben und zwar sagt er da jeder
will dass seine freunde abnimmt dass
haben sehr viele so zitiert in den
kommentaren noch mal hin geschrieben und
dazu ihre meinung dazu geschrieben zu
dem thema zwei punkte an allererster
stelle finde ich es und rasch wach auf
der menschlichen ebene wenn man eine
person in ihrer menschenwürde reduziert
also dafür runter macht krank whatever
dafür dass sie irgend einem
schönheitsideal nicht entsprechen mega
viele leute machen das nicht nur noch es
ist natürlich ist es moralisch falsch
mega viele leute mache es trotzdem
man sollte das natürlich nicht machen
also es ist falsch dass zu machen
andererseits muss man aber auch sagen
dass auch im jahre 2020 als noch erlaubt
sein muss leute darauf hinzuweisen dass
gewisse dinge ungesund für sie sind als
ich meinen wir würden ja ein tolles von
auch nicht zögern jemand zu sagen hey
warum brauchst du ist doch ungesund für
dich so darf man an anderer stelle dann
nicht sagen dieses dieses level von
übergewicht was war damit schon sehr
hoch sein muss weiß gar nicht ob das
jetzt bei ihr auf diesem level wäre das
ist auch ungesund sehr sehr heikel heute
sage ich auch jetzt gerade wo ich
darüber rede also über halt so die
körper von andern leuten zu urteilen ist
nicht easy aber man darf da auch nicht
ultra hypersensibel sein und zu sagen so
das ist ein thema zudem überhaupt
niemand mehr irgendwas sagen darf weil
es gibt doch schon ein paar objektive
aussagen wie zb dieses level ist
ungesund weil übergewicht oder
untergewicht oder whatever und diese
aussagen muss man noch machen dürfen
aber wie gesagt bei den ganzen thema ist
es sehr wichtig dass alles mit vorsicht
zu machen und mit rücksicht zu machen
aber man muss schon auch machen dürfen
das ist meine
meinung ich hatte mir gerne mal eure
meinung in die kommentare wie habt ihr
das ganze wahrgenommen war ja von anfang
an so kritisch wie sieht es jetzt wie
vielen der meine argumente dazu hättet
ihr lust auf eine interview vielleicht
auch mit ashley also mit der der
schauspieler von entstehen der sie ihre
ihrer seite darstellt wenn ja schon
beides gern in die kommentare
check hier in folge stein ist hier oben
könnte man kann ich will eine schnelle
raus macht's gut